[Music]
[Applause]
al michaels hall of fame broadcaster
sunday night football play-by-play voice
and of course it's winning your end
chargers in las vegas to battle the
raiders coverage starts at 7 eastern on
nbc
and peacock
al how are you today
hello bob barker
that's that's you right well i was up
for the job price is right
and uh after after bob stepped down they
offered me the job of the price is right
so what was the what was the david bowie
final price i think 250. 250 million
dollars
250 yeah so he's half of what
springsteen was right yeah
pretty much so what about juice newton
what do you think uh
her library
we'll go for it
what was your first concert al
oh
good question tommy dorsey
jimmy dorsey
you're not that old
i can't remember you don't remember
benny goodman
what do you want me to tell you
tchaikovsky
did you see did you see mozart
i did not see him personally but uh i
was able to log in
okay hold on al you have one of the
greatest memories that i've ever been
around when it comes to sports and you
cannot remember your first concert i
can't but i can remember the last one or
one of the most recent ones i went to a
springsteen concert i had never been
to a springsteen concert and his good
buddy is the great sitcom director jimmy
burroughs longtime friend of mine and so
jimmy took me backstage afterwards i
thought it was one of the most fantastic
things i've ever seen four hours yeah la
sports arena he gets crowd surf you know
he's in his uh mid to late 60s at that
point
going on for four four consecutive hours
and i remember walking back into the
dressing room and it was uh it was
pretty awesome to to meet the boss
himself and i said hey man i said uh
a first time caller long time listener
because i i've never been to a concert
but
to one of his but that was you know it
was inspiring
to see this guy doing what he did every
other night this is not that that long
ago
and uh
that's the last one i can remember but
the first one i've got i've got to think
about it dan i really do but when's the
last time you you approached a player
after a performance in a game like here
you're seeing springsteen as a fan but
have you ever gone up to a player after
a game just to say i just want to say or
whatever sport all the sports you've
covered
i've texted
but you know when it comes to the end of
the game we're just trying to beat the
traffic
so i mean we're out of there
we don't go down chris and i and my ship
my michelle is down in the field talking
to the star of the game but uh i've
texted a few of the guys yeah i mean
we've had some spectacular tom brady
performances
peyton manning of course through all of
those years uh aaron rodgers you know
the guys that you would
most expect and uh you know just a
little text exchange about hey that was
fantastic and
and great for the ratings too
more importantly but even after the
miracle on ice like did did you even
think about
saying something to mike eruzione for
for what happened well that's how i
found out the story of what her brooks
had said in the locker room uh before
the third period of the finland game i
ran into mike on the street in lake
placid everybody's getting ready to
leave town and i said to him because
remember the us had beaten the the
soviets on friday night but still had
one more game had to meet finland on
sunday and the game that started at 11
in the morning we're trailing
two to one going into the third period
and i said what what was it like in the
locker room before the third period and
mike said brooks got up there and he
said if you lose this game you will take
it to your bleeping grave
which was probably
as good a pep talk as has ever been
given better than anything that newt
rockne or lombardi or anybody could have
given in any locker room and you know
what when you think about what brooks
said to that team
it's 10 000 correct because these guys
instead of dining out on a gold medal 42
years ago now they would have gone
around people would have said now wait a
second you beat the soviets and you lost
to finland what
so
it was those were the perfect words that
were hunted by her brooks that day but
also your great call would have been a
casualty if they didn't win the gold
medal
do you believe in miracles wouldn't have
the same ring that it does
so if they lose to finland i probably
could have said do you believe in
debacle
but
you know it all worked out yeah and you
know rosioni of course with the with the
game-winning gold and the third period
uh
has has really dined out on this baby
i'm sorry he's he's you've met him he's
such a great guy and it's been fantastic
to watch to watch that run through the
years i i did introduce him one time the
sports illustrated sportsman of the year
and they had all these luminaries in the
audience and i'm going around the room
and i go oh there's mike rozioni
still on scholarship in america
he didn't like that that i said oh yeah
there's a guy who's still still on
scholarship for people who didn't meet
john madden that we listened to him or
we watched him you were friends with him
you were close with him
what didn't we see with john men
you know what you saw is what you got
and people say to me well what was he
really like and i said he was really
like pretty much what you saw
he was
full of life
he was full of energy
he was a great conversationalist i i
said the other day a great teacher but a
terrific listener and wanted to learn
was very curious
uh loved you know traveling around the
country
being with people
and he he enjoyed that and there wasn't
anything about john
that
said hey look you know i'm a big
celebrity i'm one of the most
recognizable people in the country no it
was none of that he was more interested
in absorbing things
than in in playing any sort of a role
going out to dinner with him was
fantastic and i mean when i think about
my seven years with him and we did
150 games together in three super bowls
all i really think about it are the
great times we had at dinner talking
about football of course but everything
but football
and
he was
he was so special by the way i've got i
was just thinking of something this
morning that really hasn't been out
there that you might be you'll be
interested in this
so john comes to me in 2002 because pat
sumrall is going to step aside
and it's about time for john to you know
maybe either move on to get a new
partner
and abc approaches him and i get john
from 2002 through 2008 seven seven
seasons
john almost came to monday night
football in 1994
which was when cbs lost the rights
fox gained the rights to the nfc
who are they going to hire this is
before they hire pat and john and and
the whole production crew
so
abc now
goes after john and there is a meeting
in new york in 90 right after this
happened in 94
between the top abc executive
and john's representative at that time
and there was a handshake
and a toast that john was going to come
to monday night football and i got the
call from our exec that night and i went
to bed that night thinking john is my
partner beginning in 1994.
the next day
rupert murdoch comes in and writes an 8
million a year check to john and that
was the end of that
and that created
this you know this
loggerhedge thing between the abc
executive
and batteries uh
excuse me and john's uh representative
at the time which uh which went on for a
lot of years but we thought we had john
in 1994.
did the network think of like
tuning him down a little bit like what i
don't know if if he was too he was so
different from everybody else so did
they try to calm him down a little bit
with his approach to being an analyst
well maybe
i don't think uh fox did i think that
you know had he come over to abc no i
mean when you if you were going to sign
john madden
to do the show you wanted to be john
madden why why would you tune him down
the the thing
with him was he had established a new
template uh people loved it he was a guy
who as you know spawned a whole bunch of
imitators
but nobody there was only one john
madden and nobody else could play the
role of john madden and be authentic
so there was no way you could do that i
know when john came to me
after he had been with pat for uh
20 or 21 years
we talked about the fact that uh
that maybe i was more i was i i spoke
more than pac did i wanted to engage
john in certain conversations which i'd
heard him through the years he would
talk about and i wanted to go deeper and
i said hey are you okay if i if we go
this way he said i'd love it
so that was how we started and then the
first game that we did together was the
hall of fame game in 2002
and dan by the time we got to the second
commercial i thought i'd work with him
for 20 years it was that simple it was
that easy
and it's tricky because as the
play-by-play guy
setting up your analyst is is is
delicate and and there's a delicate
balance in those who do it well you know
nance does it what nance does to me is
more impressive than what tony romo does
because jim has to kind of set up tony
and then weave back into the
play-by-play
how did you do that with with john where
you you getting he gets in and then gets
out and then you go back to the
play-by-play
i think when the two of us were paired
together in 2002
i had heard him for over 20 years he was
always on the bus after he did a sunday
game watching monday night football he'd
heard me
do hundreds of games
so i know fred godelli our producer at
that time and still is obviously
um fred had said to both of us
when we uh were paired
hey you guys want to do kind of a
rehearsal game we'll sit in the studio
and play a tape and i was the senior
partner at that point because john was
coming to to us
and i looked at john and i
i said i don't think we need to do this
and then john told me on the way out of
the room he said i'm glad you said that
that would have been artificial i think
john and i
when we got together understood each
other's rhythm
and there was not the remotest concern
on my part it wouldn't fold in
setting up the analyst is not
necessarily asking a question it's you
got to know what where the other guy's
brain is
and we both had that rhythm and the
great thing about john is he was so well
versed not only in football but
everything there wasn't one time i could
say something that we hadn't talked
about beforehand and know that john
wouldn't be ready for it he was he was
that good so when you're working with
somebody like that you have all the
confidence in the world you can go
anywhere
and he he's right with you we're talking
al michaels nbc sports of course and uh
the winning you're in the chargers and
the raiders
uh
is there part of you rooting for an la
based team to play in the super bowl
not necessarily because yeah i know i
live here and
whatever is going to happen uh on
february 13th i'm i'm good with that i
mean we've got some great prospective
matchups you know what i would really
like to see uh sunday night you know
what i root for in every game over time
because overtime means is drama
all announcers you know people say oh
you're rooting for this game with that
team that's garbage what you're rooting
for is drama what you're not rooting for
is dallas leading washington 42-7 at the
half
which we had you know two weeks ago
that's not what you want it's not that
you're not rooting for for one team or
the other it's i love when it gets down
to the end and you've got great strategy
and i mean the end of that like the
cincinnati kansas city game was crazy
the other day and jim and tony i thought
did a great job with that i mean you
have all these plays you know when do
you take the time out what do you do
here you got the penalties all over the
place
that's what you root for you root for
look i always wanted to do the first
overtime super bowl uh
and uh
joe and troy got it of course
28 to three i couldn't believe it you
know 2083 and that that's the game that
goes to overtime but what i really like
to see happen february 13th is like
quadruple overtime the greatest super
bowl of all time
how's your golf game by the way
thanks for asking
would you give me a swing thought this
is so you know i have on my phone here i
know if you can well i can't show it to
you right now
i have swing thoughts
i have 620 that's the problem that's the
problem i know the brain gets in your
way you know that right yes so and then
what do i do do i start from the top and
go down and then you know i have a lot
of you know a few swing thoughts are in
caps a few swing swing thoughts have you
know like like uh words you can't use on
on this show then there are the others
with like nine exclamation points
and when marty fish who's a pal belongs
to you know bel air
marty you know was winning the um
tournament in tahoe a couple of years
ago and he's going into the final round
but i sent him my whole list
i said
pick any five at my expense
so he he won it anyway i think he threw
it in the garbage nick foundation you
know
it's it's it's in your
what you need in golf is a lobotomy
that's what you need
but great athletes don't think they've
already thought before they get into
that position right and we always go
what were you thinking and a lot of
athletes go i i wasn't thinking anything
damn when you hit a great dog shot
and it's like six seconds later and
you're thinking well wait a minute what
did i do
that's why that game is unbelievably
fascinating and uh but right now i'm
kind of i'm in as
uh
jerry jones said about dak prescott a
few weeks ago i'm in a slump
all right but i hope like that could
come out of that slump and have the kind
of game that dak had against washington
is that your office at your house
it's uh yeah it's upstairs and i have
behind me well evans field because i
grew up in brooklyn and i love new york
and the empire state building is there
and uh the bay bridge means we lived in
the bay area so um
i move all over the house sometimes with
the kitchen table sometimes with the
dining room table some sometimes i'm up
here what's the best piece of sports
memorabilia you have
uh what's the best piece
i have a laminated ticket to the u.s
soviet hockey game
somewhere downstairs yeah and i don't i
don't collect a lot of stuff
uh and my wife actually gave me a
montage on the 25th anniversary of a lot
of great stuff that had happened up
until that point
and that's about it you know and by the
way i think i have
a ton of sports illustrators which my
wife has finally taken out of the house
she did about four years ago and put
them in public storage
so because i mean they were just taking
up too much room so if you come out here
the next time we'll go to public storage
and i'll take you all the way back to
like the
1960s yeah of course that's fun i i
would go with you
you know with the uh the advent of now
everybody's gambling and you can talk
about it openly it kind of hurts that
little subtle over-under
i mean it does yeah
you know i can still jam it in there a
little bit uh
but right i mean pete there are people
who still get a kick out of it but these
days um it's it's it's completely
different you don't have to uh hide it i
mean the leagues are all in in
partnership with all of the the
draftkings and
and the caesars and the rest of the
operations
but you know i just
it's i have a lot of fun with it dan
but i just hope that people don't bet
the rent money or the mortgage money on
it just
it's the old thing about you know do it
responsibly and hopefully people will
will do it responsibly it's fun to do
there's no question you you're more
engaged in the game but when you get you
know over the top with it
that's dangerous you know that
great to talk to you and uh good luck
good luck
when you take the swing back
yes go johnny
miller
oh okay johnny
miller
roger
staubach
that's the giveaway tiger
no no no no no no you need
i need to come back
you need you need two syllables johnny
miller
okay let me write that down here hold on
this is
647. thank you dan thank you
that's uh the great al michaels hall of
fame broadcaster sunday night football
the winner grabs the afc wild card spot
it'll be the raiders and the chargers